يصل زعماء الافارقه الى واشنطن للمشاركه
في قمه امريكيه افريقيه تستمر ثلاثه ايام
الدعوه توجهت لرؤساء 49 دوله افريقيه
ولرئيس الاتحاد الافريقي كسلان ولم
تدعينيا والسودان ومالي وبوركينا وسبب
بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين ان هذه البلدان
احدث التغيرات غير دستوريه في حكوماتها
من خلالها
القاره السمراء من السياسات الامريكي
على مدار سنوات الثلاث المقبله
التحدي
في افريقيا وحولوا التركيز على تحسين
العلاقه مع القاده الافارقه
وهذا يعني خلق المزيد من المسارات بالتدفق
الحر للافكار والمعلومات والاستثمار
افريقيا وواشنطن التي تخشى من الهيمنه
الصينيه في العالم حذرت الافارقه مرارا من
انفاق بكين مليارات الدولار على البناء
التحتيه سيضع القاره السمراء تحت نير
الديون الصينيه كما وتراقب الولايات
المتحده التغلغل الروسي وترى ان موسكو
اصبحت من ابرز مزود افريقيا بالاسلحه
ومرتزقه فاجن الروس موجود في العديد من
النقاط الساخنه بافريقيا
وستكون القيمه الامريكيه الافريقيه مناسبه
لاعلان بيضا عن دعم الولايات المتحده
للحصول الاتحاد الافريقي على مكانه رسميه
في مجموعه العشرين الاقتصادات الكبرى كما
يدعم الرئيس الامريكي ان شاء مقعدا
افريقيا دائما في مجلس الامن الدولي
[موسيقى]